all of the tmg studios content is in one
place every podcast every episode every
bonus episode all ad free and you can
access it for just six dollars a month
with a membership to tmgstudios.tv
now i'm just becoming a family fun
center connoisseur because i go to one
for the go-karts and i go to one for the
bowling and so i went to another place
called power play that [ __ ] was straight
out of the 90s i was like in tears
walking around that place it's it's an
arcade it's meant for kids they got like
a
toddler's area you can just leave your
kid so they have go-karts and so they
have two tiers right and i got sunned so
[ __ ] hard because you know i can see
there's like this cart in that car i'm
like oh okay like how much of the
go-karts man the kid's like 14
i'm like all right cool how much for the
faster ones
19 i'm like cool we'll do we'll do uh
two uh sessions each on the fast ones he
goes oh well you're going to have to
qualify
no way i was like
excuse me do you know who i am yeah
literally a picture of me in the red
bull yeah yeah
i'm max verstappen's biggest fan yeah do
you know who this is
this is max or savan's biggest fan it's
my podcast this is my podcast co-host
so you're going to let me in that faster
part we get in these carts and they are
pieces of [ __ ] okay i go out there i'm
two seconds off the qualifying time i'm
like
wait no no no no wait wait wait wait
figure out the track okay i'm gonna
figure out the lines right
so then we go out again and i like i
figure out like like
i get back out there i'm like because i
didn't warm the tires up all right so
you know get back out there second
session first lap i'm like sending the
[ __ ] sideways the kids like looking at
me like what the [ __ ] what's wrong with
this dude he doesn't even know i put
heat in the tires i felt the grip i'm
like for sure i got to be close 33.6 but
tom gets
32.6 so he's a hundredth off there's a
tenth off from
the qualifying time and tom's like i
don't know man looks like i smoked you i
was like
oh my god i can see your brain shorting
out
yeah yeah oh dude tom just kept it going
he's like yeah you're pissed huh maybe
you should warm up the tires a little
bit more yeah oh
here smack them around a little bit alex
knows i'm about to punch the employee
yeah right yeah yeah
and he's like hey man
slap hey slap's happening man he knows
i'm about to slap this guy at work and
alex is like he's like there's no way
this is accurate he's trying to make me
feel better and i'm like
it's just they're
tom does me a solid tom's like get in my
cart he's like trust me he's like the
one i drove i'm like telling you is like
it's way faster okay i get in and as
soon as it starts rolling i can feel the
torque i'm like this thing is [ __ ]
this is way faster this whole [ __ ]
thing is rigged at a place called power
play yeah well so
i get in find the grip immediately 31.5
whole second off in the piece of [ __ ]
cart
so i walk away so what's the qualifying
time 30 32 32 okay and i full second and
then so we get back in there and then
the kid goes yeah so it looks like you
qualified and the way he said it was
like he was enjoying
that i wasn't qualifying right i was
like you little [ __ ] third time's a
charm eh yeah oh
oh so switch cars huh yeah yeah
i could feel it any but then he really
dug it in he's like so you've only
qualified once you're gonna need to
qualify again if you want to go to the
faster carts i'm like
i have a show buddy
but if i had more time i'd be in that
faster car i thought you're going to say
and you you can have tickets
just let me go in the fast
he'd be like i don't want these man
i'm fully okay wait what kind of
[ __ ] rule is that they have to
qualify twice that guy was just [ __ ]
with you well no so i i asked him you
know i tried to try to slip in a little
birnacular see if i could get him to you
know come off that rule so so so the
faster one was
then it's four strokes right um like by
how many cc's you think
i know terms and he's like yeah i know
terms and he goes i couldn't tell you
man um
so i was like
[ __ ] guy i was like you know i drive
two strokes back at home man so
i'm like do they did they make you
qualify because people [ __ ] up in the in
the he's like yeah people they they
crash i'm like okay all right all right
listen man give me these [ __ ] faster
cards
i vented about this at one of the shows
and one of the girls goes you just got
to slip him with 50. i'm like the the
ride is 15 bucks i'm not paying 50 what
get the [ __ ] out of here i bought a card
for a hundred dollars i dropped a
hundred dollars of power play because
you get 35 extra worth of tokens we go
back there the second day and we try to
get on the go-karts again and they're
like you went back [ __ ] yeah twice it
was pre-show we had an hour i'm like
let's see okay dude we had like 75
dollars on the card okay yeah that's
true i'm like i'm just trying to burn it
so we go back and the kid is like yeah
man it's a two-hour wait [ __ ] you is
this the same kid no it's a different
kid and i held on my phone again i'm
like do you know my [ __ ] co-host
[Laughter]
his co-worker told him he's like if this
[ __ ] guy comes in just make sure he
doesn't get the faster card just say
whatever you can so then tom does the
funniest [ __ ] ever and tom
he does it he goes
there's no way to get us in earlier oh
yeah and the kid goes actually there is
and gets you one of 15 minutes i
couldn't believe it worked and tom was
like hey sometimes you got to ask so
we're walking out there i see these two
kids playing on a crane game i tap on my
gay guys everyone in your life is going
to die
so burn up this power play card run it
because you haven't you gave it to him
yeah oh that's nice i was like you have
an hour left to live that's nice you
know i just i just like tapped and was
like yeah i think there's like i don't
know 50 on this and then they were like
the sound the kid made was so funny he
was like
whoa
he just stared at me through his glasses
like hanging halfway off his face he's
just whoa
and his brother like looked at him and
he looked at me and then his brother
like couldn't believe it and then tom
was like yeah i think there's like 20 on
this one they're just like
so you never got on the faster ones no
yeah i was pissed big rip yeah that's
too bad i do have to
mention the bourbon guy you know we're
getting something to eat right a corner
bar
in the place
the guy is like
trying like bourbon and whiskey i can't
remember i've never seen someone like
sit and like you ever you ever seen
anyone do this like let me try that one
i've never seen anyone do that in terms
of bourbon no just like at a bar
like
cruising through their collection oh
yeah if it's like a big like beer tap
menu or something like that like if you
go to like some beer hall that has like
100 beers no it was it wasn't even like
that it was just kind of it was like a
bar yeah she's like we're looking
through like well drinks and being like
yeah kind of yeah like nothing on the
shelf let me try the uh yeah yeah vodka
soda
rum and coke
well i'll get one of those what is that
some sort of cool craft cocktail you
guys do he's picking out from the
bottles there's there's only like six
bottles of oh so he's looking at like
the bottles yeah yeah you know he's
being annoying like let me get the one
the the oddly shaped one he's got this
kid this dude has horrible
like adjectives can't describe anything
to save his life if that dude had to
tell his wife how to like defuse a bomb
or something yeah they'd be dead okay
you know like it feels like reading from
a manual like he'd be like cut the one
that's a different shade from blue yeah
yeah
complementary color to blue yeah so he's
trying to tell the guy you know get this
bottle he's like yeah the the funny
looking one it's the only one that looks
weird and then the guy's like ah which
one is it you tell me when to stop
he goes he goes you say when there's
only six bottles and the guy's voice is
this one
what
is that
oh
this noisy [ __ ] in there and the guy's
like when and and yeah the guy's looking
at him like
he's like what when when was that that
one then when so they finally figured
out it was like i just wanted to be like
it's the one that's shaped like a vagina
it's the one in the middle so the guy's
sitting there he's sipping it he's
drinking it you know he's swishing it
around smelling it whatever the [ __ ]
he gets to the very end of his glass
hey buddy uh
sorry to say i got a little problem with
my bourbon here got a floater this is
just a little mint leaf
just rummaging around at the bottom and
the guy goes i'm sorry about that you
know it must have slipped through and i
you know do i'll clean it out i'll i'll
i'll make sure gives him another glass
for free because it's a [ __ ] mint
leaf
in the bourbon the guy pounds it and he
walks out i'm like
smart i would just go home and drink i
definitely brought the mint leaf with
him yeah it was just
yeah yeah i just couldn't believe that
hey supposed to be a severed mouse head
yeah
in my whiskey